quoique si nous sommes bons jours à tous
je me présente j'ai l'honneur matin
c'est juste la bienvenue à cette
nouvelle chronique kapatakan
donc permettez moi tout d'abord de vous
redire bonjour donc après quelques mois
d'absence je vous revient en force avec
cette nouvelle chronique
je pourrais aborder le dans une
chronique subséquentes peut-être les
raisons qui m'ont poussé à prendre un
peu de temps pour moi puis les raisons
pour lesquelles déjà envie de revenir
faire des chroniques avec l'espoir
autochtone et radio canada
mais le sujet de ma chronique
d'aujourd'hui il est en fait la raison
pour laquelle je décide de sortir de mon
mutisme
c'est évidemment le sujet chaud le sujet
de l'heure donc le conflit le qui oppose
la nation huronne wendat et la nation dp
quoi gamine notre site la nation une
machouillette
tout d'abord je dois dire en tant que
innu de la communauté de mâchouiller ans
maintenant directement interpellé par le
conflit que lui en ce moment pour les
deux nations mais j'avais envie
aujourd'hui de peut-être vous partager
mes réflexions par rapport par rapport à
ce conflit leur coût par rapport à
l'impact je pense que ça va les
maintenir à flot surtout que ça peut
avoir donc on se transporte dès
maintenant du côté de la réserve
faunique des laurentides et donc pour
pour l'occasion j'ai tout comme tout bon
correspondant de guerre en zone de
guerre j'arbore aujourd'hui ma veste la
plus orangé pour être sûrs d'être bien
en vue le des chasseurs qui se trouvent
des deux côtés du territoire
donc on se retrouve dans la réserve
faunique des laurentides je vous
rappelle rapidement de lit les
événements qui ont eu lieu dans la fin
de semaine du 5 juin dernier à eux deux
campements des membres de la première
nation des peco gamine notre longue
liste de machouillettes qui ont été
saccagés
dans la réserve faunique des laurentides
et
les gestes auraient été posées de parts
ou encore été cautionnée par la nation
huronne wendat qui laissait sur place
note indiquant que le territoire sur
lesquels les campements et allait être
érigées c'était un territoire qui était
revendiqué par la nation huronne wendat
comme étant un territoire exclusif
faisons partie d'une once you donc leur
territoire il faut savoir que le conflit
qui oppose la nation huronne wendat et
la nation des brigadiers minute remonte
par ailleurs je dois ça fait quand même
plusieurs années toutes les dominations
revendiquent le territoire qui se trouve
dans la réserve faunique des laurentides
donc d'un côté on a les hurons wendat
qui à travers un traité qui aurait été
conclu dans les années 1760 le fameux
traité marie disent que cette portion de
territoire loi fait partie intégrante et
exclusive de leurs nos ambitieux et du
côté d une ou deux matches d'où viens tu
n'en fait-on on se base un peu plus le
sur l'occupation ancestrales et
historique du territoire et sur la
jurisprudence pour dire que cette partie
de territoire là et bien et la partie à
la nation des peccadilles minutes tu
crois que c'est important de le
mentionner les
les innu de machouillettes ne revendique
pas ce territoire de façon exclusive
dont qui disent plutôt que de telles qu
on serait une zone partagée entre les
deux nations et qu' il y aurait
cohabitation possible sur ce territoire
donc
évidemment aujourd'hui dans ma chronique
j'ai répondu sûrement envie de
d'apporter tout l'historique de la
revendication py qui raison qui a tort
là dedans je pense que on s'entendre
pour dire que historiquement des
autochtones et pas juste les nuls mais
aussi d'autres nations ont fréquenté
cette portion de territoire leur et qui
aujourd'hui mène la nation huronne
wendat ben c'est une nation qui occupe
également ce territoire donc je pense
qu'on s'envoie pour dire ça
après on remonte jusqu'à 15 pour prouver
la l'occupation du territoire on laisse
trop les politiques débattent entre eux
deux qui auront raison au final mais je
pense que les réflexions que j'ai ne
peuvent pas être amené ont ce qu'on
pourra peut-être inspirer nos
politiciens dans leurs réflexions qu'ils
auront à ce que les légumes des
négociations qu'ils auront entre eux
pour la suite de ce dossier donc un un
des éléments importants que j'avais
envie d'aborder c'est surtout l'impact
l'impact corps ce genre de conflits sur
entre autres l'image qu'on se fait des
autochtones
je trouve vraiment sorte de majeur parce
qu'encore une fois l'image que ça
renvoie de ces cubains les autochtones
ils n'arrivent pas à s'entendre entre
eux qui sont toujours en conflit sur le
territoire il tech qui pis est ce que
plus un territoire qui est ce que plus
les plus grandes ressources puis
comme moi quand je pense à celle de
l'image souvent que j'ai entendu c'est
celle du gouvernement qui se frotte les
mains comme celui qui se dit bon là
c'est parfait pendant qu'ils sont en
train de se chicaner entre euros mais
ils sont pas en train de se chicaner
avec nous puis je me dis au final c'est
juste dommage hommes pour des instituts
des autochtones on n'y gagne rien là
dedans
la loi sur les indiens elle a bien fait
son travail à ce niveau là
moi je trouve que des fois t'es diviser
pour mieux régner
j'aimerais sont qu' il y avait il y
avait d'autres ça dans la loi sur les
indiens puis aujourd'hui les communautés
en tout cas pendant longtemps elles ont
été chacun pour soi dans les communautés
travail en silo
par rapport à leurs négociations par
rapport à la recherche de financements
par rapport à tous ces éléments à
l'appui au lieu de travail et en gagne
pain et s'était amené à travail anses
aujourd'hui on voit le on y donne moins
en moins là dedans pitt une volonté les
communautés à travailler ensemble mais
cet exemple est un exemple concret que
ben
la loi sur les indiens de bien fait son
travail parce que aujourd'hui on est en
train de s'obstiner des nations
autochtones ensemble pour cette portion
territoire leur puis ultimement
pendant qu'on est en train de se
chicaner sur ces choses l'homme ne
consentent pas à travailler sur les
enjeux qu'on a en commun c'est important
de mentionner parce que au-delà des
différences qu'on peut avoir entre les
communautés en tri-nations on est
beaucoup plus dangereux commun je pense
qu'il faudrait davantage se concentrer
là dessus dans le futur puis de garde
des centaines de se dire 20 ont peur des
chicanes y des éléments sur lesquels on
peut ne pas s'entendre mais il ya
tellement d'éléments sur lesquels on
s'entend plus focus on sur ce qui nous
relie au lieu de ce qui nous divise
dans un deuxième temps ben évidemment ça
donne et bac pro juste aux yeux du
public mais ça m'a aussi un impact sur
les membres dans les communautés moi
j'ai vu le récemment passé sur les
réseaux sociaux des des commentaires
portrait de leur mieux
concernant ce dossier là beaucoup de
commentaires négatifs en fait l'envers
le conseil de la nation huronne wendat
ou encore de ses membres je trouve que
c'est vraiment dommage parce que encore
une fois j'ai l'impression que ça
alimente l'espèce de stéréotypes et de
préjugés qu'on se fait que les hurons
wendat placer des guerriers et puis que
encore une fois mais ils vont au front
comme des vrais guerriers mais ultime en
moi j'en connais beaucoup le démon de la
nation huronne wendat qui s'est pas
seulement des guerriers là je veux dire
que oui ils peuvent revendiquer comme
n'importe quelle autre nation autochtone
aujourd'hui revendique ses droits mais
j'ai l'impression que ça envoie encore
une mauvaise image que je trouve que
c'est c'est mais je trouve ça dommage
pour eux en fait parce qu'on le voit le
récemment l'opinion publique pense que
l'opinion de tout temps beaucoup à aller
en faveur de la nation des peco de
minutes puis très peu le semble
cautionner les gestions et et qui ont
été cautionnés par
le conseil de la nation huronne wendat
donc je pense que là bas on ne rien
gagner à salir une autre communauté à
salir un nous conseille de prendre nos
gouvernements
donc je trouve que c'est dommage pige
ans quand j'invite le sud et celles qui
sont présents sur les réseaux se soit
rester poli quand même parce que
derrière mon écran c'est facile de
s'envoyer promener puis de se vider le
fond de sa pensée maintenant on est des
autochtones on est des êtres humains
puissent est important de respecter je
pense
et puis ben finalement je conclurai en
parlant un peu peut-être du ras-le-bol
que j'ai par rapport à sopi je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est partagé par
d'autres jeunes je sais pas si quelque
chose de générationnel le métier moi
j'étais en contact avec d'autres jeunes
autochtones qui se disent mais pourquoi
on est encore là pourquoi on est encore
dans l'évier girl qui ont lieu depuis 40
50 60 ans entre les communautés puis
c'est vrai que des fois j'ai
l'impression que c'est de la vieille
politique de négocier à coups de menaces
à coups de bulldozers à coups de mises
en demeure je veux dire on arrête pas de
prôner en tant qu'autochtones
le dialogue l'importance de dialoguer
ensemble pour mieux se comprendre
pis je me demandais pourquoi on tend pas
vers cette c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on
en arrive à cette escalade qui au final
a même avoué ne rien de bon à rien de
positif
dit finalement vain je pense que en
conclusion je n'inviterai peut-être ces
politiciens qui pensent que les menaces
que
des bulldozers que les mises en demain
ben ça peut être productif a peut-être
passer leur chemin puis à laisser la
place aux jeunes qui qui ont envie de
se rapprocher de nouveau leur petite
commune de dialogue de respect de
partage
puis aux jeunes dans je dirais prenez-le
à votre place faut pas attendre de se la
faire donner des fois il faut la prendre
et je pense que dans
l'avenir il faut de reprendre deux
places de plus amples puis remettre nos
valeurs de la vie donc c'était mes
réflexions pour pour cette chronique je
suis extrêmement heureux de vous
retrouver donc je vous souhaite une
excellente fin de journée il ya bientôt